what's up reject nation i got with me
today
juliet soro that's how you say it right
yeah i got it all right juliet
you might have seen her on the channel a
few months ago but since the last time
she's been here
she's been killing it her instagram's
been blowing up you guys will want to go
follow her because she's been killing it
over there she's been working with
terran tactical
and she was even part of this really
cool short film
that i kept promising to put on the
community page that i just haven't done
but i watched it and it's really
freaking sweet
it's called tacticats episode zero it's
like this anime
infused action heroine type of deal it's
really freaking cool like i loved it
quite a bit
i'll put a link in the description box
for you guys to go follow i won't let
her speak
once this entire time i'll just do all
the talking for her
i love how fast you are about it so it's
okay yeah guys give her some follows
she's earned it she deserves it because
she's working her ass off during this
time and then
i was gonna film cobra kai reaction
earlier and then i found out
you watched this series yours you even
met the guy who plays chris martin cope
yeah
well we went to the same party he's a
friend of terence well still
that's better than i've ever done in my
life so
juliet now that we're caught up on cobra
kai are you excited to watch the trailer
i am i hadn't even known that the
trailer came out so
i know most people don't let's do this
we'll theorize briefly but thanks for
being here
[Music]
i thought i was doing the right thing
but i failed
the you is you got soft and we paid the
price
you want cobra kai it's yours
[Music]
give us the new footage new footage
[Music]
yeah here we go here we go
we can't let them suffer because of our
issues
the only way to end this is by working
together
so what do you say yes
they're teaming up
only weak or strong
dude he's got a beer tango and cash were
narcotics detectives oh i'm sorry
you do realize neither one of you were
cops
oh it's the point of reason yeah
[Music]
is it just words that are meaningless
oh
the world doesn't just get hanging
that's the wife right
you want something you have to crawl
across the floor use your damn teeth if
you have to
yeah i'm so pumped right now
yep oh god
sorry you felt like a chair
wait a minute
wait ah let's wait for the trailer
i gotta rewind that back for a second
what happened
i'm pretty sure these people are from
karate kid part
two it's been ages since i've seen it i
think i saw one where they go to japan
yeah that's that's the villain in karate
kid too gosh
are you serious and i think that's the
love interest from karate kid too
i'm not sure i'm pretty confident that's
the villain though
oh man now we gotta go and watch karate
i thought
i'm so amazed that they really brought
everybody
back but they haven't brought back the
first girlfriend yet
true elizabeth's shoes true all right
that was awesome juliet
what'd you think i feel very pumped yeah
well i've been waiting because like
truthfully daniel and johnny could be
best friends
yes they really tried yes and so i'm
really excited because we did see like a
snippet of that and like
i forget season one or two like where
they go to the restaurant they go to the
bar
yeah and so it was like yeah yeah be
friends and then and then no
but i feel like in this season they're
really gonna come back
it seems like it was headed that way
this whole time right yeah this whole
time and it and it really looks like
they're
gonna deliver on that promise well they
have a common common enemy now
yeah that mother effort he's going down
we hate him was that dang we do hey we
hashtag we hate him today daniel
larusso's wife
i'm such an [ __ ] for not knowing her
name and there's one moment here
around the 1 minute and 23 second mark
where it looks like
amanda larusso who is her name
slaps crease so she's actually if you
really dodges if you really
aren't no no i think i think if you slow
it down it's pretty obvious he's not
getting it
actually
you can't actually hit the actors but it
looks like she's going to be taking a
stand
she's getting tougher and then you have
rob she already was tough
she already was she just wasn't getting
into the nitty-gritty but it seemed like
before she was kind of like
i'm gonna stay out of this you guys are
a bunch of weirdos and now she's
realizing more like you guys are a bunch
of children
exactly yeah it means the way she even
talks to johnny and danny here
she finds this whole thing so i don't
know toxic or something
exactly so with that in mind it's like
it looks like she's actually getting
involved in like you're ruining east
valley high
they're doing karate during a soccer
game what the hell's going on here
yeah i love her she's just the voice of
reason she's a strong character yeah
very strong character but i also find it
funny
how an east valley high how corrupted by
karate
this high school you'll never see that i
dude i'm just like
like in what high school does something
like this actually happen i know right
well i wonder that every time i watch
anything that has
high school in it it's like that's a
fair point i just
was like so exaggerated but the season
looks fun it looks like uh
like you said pump me up kind of thing
with the combination of them coming
together
bringing back these karate kid two
characters if i'm correct about that i'm
not 100 sure i wouldn't know
yeah i didn't see it well shame on you i
know i should have brought someone by
i didn't have to watch them no i kept
calling everyone whoever take part i
can't do everything
most people i think haven't and i feel
like for prep for this show most people
only watch the first movie and then went
into the series
but then also with miguel last season
i don't know about you did he kind of
get on your nerves because he was going
down like a dark
antagonistic he started to he started
too
this time around it looks like they're
bringing him back to be a character you
can really root for
be a hero of sorts and robbie what'd you
think about him i liked robbie in the
last couple seasons
i thought he was much better in the fir
in this and the second season
oh yeah but this time around did you
notice his haircut
very upset about it you don't like you
don't like his haircut i like i like the
long hair you prefer the long look oh
yeah but yeah i just i like long hair in
general that was top priority for him to
get a haircut
and who's the in this diva girl from
last season what is she like
we hate her i don't remember what
happened with her character is she
getting
the homewrecker and she was like one of
the first girls
or in like i think the second season to
join kurokai and then that's how she met
miguel when they started
oh yeah she's like a real she's a bully
this is like the rise of the heroes and
villains all at once
right yeah so do you think robbie and
miguel are gonna become
best of friends in this season i don't
know
well if their dads are like coming
together
i don't know because i feel like
miguel's gonna be in the hospital for
most of this season
really yeah having that true recovery
i don't know we'll see we'll see i
wonder if crease is finally going to die
probably not maybe this will have a
super dark ending
where they just beat him to death all of
the kids together just stomping on his
face
we'll see because if they did that
they'd have to bring like a really
strong villain for the next season
that's he's the best villain they got
right now maybe this whole time
elizabeth shu his girlfriend from uh
rocky his girlfriend girlfriend from
karate kid one
uh has secretly been training in karate
and now she's going to become the
ultimate villain and wants to take
revenge against danny for breaking her
heart
that would be we're all about theories i
mean
theories i wouldn't
it's so cool watching this series
because it's all in my neighborhood
it's all it's all around in the valley
right yeah
i know that place rosita encino i mean
it's awesome
it's like right down the street it's
right right now actually yeah
it's so cool if you want to hunt us down
in the next hour you know
you could probably do it give away our
position it looks like they're really
bringing back the heart and the soul
especially with the
miguel relationship because it was
really upsetting what was watching what
happened to him in the last one
granted that was an epic high school
fight at the end it was
i mean it was like i'm always like where
are all the
where are the teachers like but that's
what i wonder literally in
every high school film or tv series i
ever watched like there's this giant
crazy fight where are the teachers like
this would never happen at my high
school who's your favorite character in
the show
um johnny yeah johnny
definitely i think that's the thing that
surprised everyone about this right was
that everyone turned in for danny
larusso and then come to find out
johnny's like
the most compelling character it's so
interesting because you see
what the original film was like from his
perspective yes and it's like
wait like he you know you think he's the
bully this whole time but like he felt
like he was getting
punched in the face by daniel like you
know the whole time
and not really realizing i'm wondering
now with the way that have this trailer
played out
miyagi dojo and cobra kai are somehow
gonna join forces and become because
they already have a season four in mind
so i'm wondering if they're gonna become
one big dojo or
if johnny and danny are going to have
another fallout again and why were they
beating up people at a mechanic shop
when they were when like daddy did like
this roundhouse kick to someone at a
bigger oh yeah
when they because are they becoming like
vigilantes or something
because they make that joke about tango
and cash and i'm like wait are you guys
like actually becoming like people who
are
hunting on this it looks like the school
is just so corrupted by karate
i know who knew karate could
cause so much it's so funny how the
first season felt like grounded in
reality and then by the time you get to
the second season
it was just like crazy yeah yeah
but somehow it still remains so good i
know it was
yeah very good well juliet i'm glad that
we have this show in common
and um guys what do you think about this
cobra kai season 3 trailer
john and i will be covering it for the
youtube channel you best believe it
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell hit that like button
follow this one on instagram link in the
description
box check out tactic cats yes
tactical is there a follow-up coming is
there another one that's going to come
out
um not solidified yet
not sure not sure it's up in the air can
i be the fourth tactic
can i audition i um i'll have to think
about that and
bring it up with the board i just think
that i'd be a good fit
okay i just think that i have the
physique
the looks the long hair the long hair
helps i believe i
i hate to say it i'm i'd probably be the
best looking one in the group
okay um well you know i'll i'll think
about it
i'll think about it i just think i'll
write your name
you gotta go to the next step you gotta
upgrade per
follow-up and i believe i am that
edition okay
thank you for your pitch you're welcome
[Music]